NIKLAS JANSEN: Why was
audio so important?
I'd like to understand why audio
is so important for Blinkist
is first, you have to understand
commuting and traffic jams.
So this is the car
version of a traffic jam.
Because we're in New
York, I thought maybe
we'd also look at the human
version of a traffic jam.
Maybe let's do a quick
Q&A. Who of you commutes
more than 30 minutes per day?
Like most people.
What are you doing?
Are you consuming content
when you're commuting?
Who is listening to
audio when they commute?
Other question--
like five years ago,
did you listen to audio
when you were commuting?
So that's very
interesting, because we
started as a text-only company,
just producing text content.
And we started speaking
to a lot of customers.
So text worked well.
We kept growing, but
not crazy growth.
So we started talking to
customers to understand,
are we missing
something in order
to really convert more
people to subscription
or to retain those
subscribers for longer?
So we started talking to
a lot of people in the US,
because the US is naturally
our biggest market.
We are a German,
Berlin-based company,
but US was our biggest
market from day one.
And what we realized is that a
lot of our customers and users
would tell us that,
hey, I like what you do,
but I don't have time
to read Blinkist.
I already have-- I'm
reading "The New York Times"
or "The Wall Street Journal."
I don't have time
to read Blinkist.
But actually, I'm commuting
every day 30 minutes,
an hour, like two hours,
and I would have time
to listen to content.
I would really love to
learn something new when
I commute in my car or in the
subway, but there's no product
or there's no offering
which really helps
me to learn something new.
And this clear insight really
struck with us, saying,
oh, look.
There's a need.
People want to learn something
new when they commute,
but there's not a real good
chance for them to do that,
because there's
not a real option
for them to acquire
new knowledge when
basically yes, they say
their hands are busy
but their mind is free.
So you can't really read,
because you're moving.
You could listen, but there
is no option for that.
So what we did is we
talked a lot about that.
So having this clear
insight, nobody
would say, well, go off
and try something out
and just build a product
and see if it works.
Back at this point, we
were maybe 15 people,
so it felt like a very big
decision for us to say, OK,
we're going to start
producing audio content.
We're going to
change the product
from a text-only product
to an audio product.
And as it is with
these big decisions,
we kept pushing off this
decision for a while.
At some point, we were sitting
in a room-- six, seven people--
and we talked about the
topic of audio again.
And at this time, growth
had slowed down a little bit
in terms of new subscribers.
And we said, OK.
It felt like, OK,
it's now or never.
Either we try audio
now or we will never
have a chance to try it again.
So we were sitting in this room
discussing the topic of audio
again.
And I don't know
really what changed,
but suddenly everyone's super
excited saying, yeah, let's
try it.
Let's just do it.
So we went off and said,
OK, let's try audio.
Let's make a plan.
But what's very
important is that we
tried to do this in a
very structured way.
So we basically
set two principles,
or we created a framework
for us that said first,
let's be very clear
about our goals
and expectations of audio.
And second, let's
make it very easy
for us to get out of it if
our expectations are not met.
So what the first
one means is let's
be very clear about what
we expect from audio.
It's we said, OK,
first, it's going
to increase the usability
of the product, which
means more people are likely
to convert to Blinkist,
because there's now room.
There is a time when
they can use Blinkist,
and therefore, they would
convert to the product.
Second, we thought with
audio, the perceived value
of the product might be
higher, so we could actually
charge more for Blinkist
than we could charge before.
In terms of make
it easy to get out,
we said to ourselves, OK,
instead of investing a million
to that, building a new
team, hiring people,
let's do a different approach.
Let's find a couple of
people within the company
that are super excited and
passionate about audio.
Let's give them a little bit--
just create an outline
of what we need in order
to go to the market
with an audio product,
and then let's give
them full autonomy.
Let them run and
figure something out,
and what they will build
over three or four months,
we're going to launch, and
then see if audio works.
So what we did--
we had just five people
across the company.
One person from content,
one person from marketing,
one person from tech,
all excited about audio.
They were musicians or
podcast aficionados back then.
And we said, OK, here
is a small budget.
We need 50 audio
versions to launch that.
We need an audio
player on the app.
You have like three months.
Try it out.
And they just
like-- because they
were so passionate
and motivated,
and excited about it, you
didn't need to motivate them.
They were just basically working
like crazy for three months
because they really wanted to
move forward with the audio.
And this is really how
we could set up audio
to test for audio
without any new hires,
still with a company
of 15 people,
and really basically creating
a second product-- a product
we didn't have before.
So end of 2014, we
finally launched audio,
and this is just three months
after we made the decision.
So the decision we
kept pushing off
for nearly a year, because it
felt like such a big project
and such a big commitment.
In the end, we were able to make
it happen within three months.
And as George said, this
launch changed the trajectory
of the business and of
the company completely,
and I think it's the main
driver for the revenue growth
we have seen in the
last three years.
It grew revenue, or it was
important for the business
side for two reasons.
Or it was so important because
it increased the lifetime
value of our customers
tremendously,
and this mostly for two reasons.
The first one, and this
is an old screenshot,
but what you can see, we
introduced a new subscription
tier called Premium.
We were not as smart
as the guys at Tinder,
so we didn't pay too
much attention on naming.
We just said we had
Plus and Premium.
That sounds really cool.
If I had to make
the decision again,
I probably would
do it differently.
Maybe something like Gold and--
[LAUGHTER]
So you still are number one.
We are trying, but
maybe next year.
But what is important?
We said OK.
As I said, we wanted
to increase price,
so we created a new
price tier, which
was way higher than
the initial price tier,
so it was more than
50% more expensive
than the initial price
that we had before.
And what's also important
is we also raised the price
for the non-audio price, too.
So just to make this clear,
Premium includes audio.
Plus didn't include audio.
And we also had
a Premium feature
connect to Evernote
and [INAUDIBLE] person.
So we increased the price
so the price for Premium
was 50% higher than
the initial price,
and we also increased the price
for the Plus subscription,
which didn't change at all.
It was the same
subscription as before,
but we felt like now the product
has a higher perceived value,
so we increased that
price too, which
just was really important for us
in terms of increasing lifetime
value.
Maybe a note on pricing and
how we arrived at these price
points is pretty--
there's no magic behind it.
We basically just looked
at comparable products
like Headspace back
then and note, oh, they
charge around $80 per year.
And we were charging
$40 at this time,
so we were basically
under-priced
compared to other products.
So let's just do $80 as
well, because what we learned
is that pricing
is often relative.
It's very hard for
you to say OK, I'm
willing to pay this amount of
money for this type of value
I'm getting from this product.
But what people are very
good at is comparing.
So they say, oh, I pay
$10 for Netflix per month
and I get unlimited movies and
series, which is $120 per year.
So I'll pay $80 for
Blinkist, where I get maybe
unlimited book summaries
and text and audio.
That sounds like a fair deal.
So this is how we
got to the price,
by just looking at what
our peers are charging
and go with this price
point, because this
is what people would expect.
So that's the first point
why it really helped
increase the lifetime value.
The second point, and
it's very obvious as well,
is just increased retention.
Because audio created
a new way for people
to consume content
at times where there
was no competition back then.
So people who used
audio sticked around
for longer, and
therefore, renewals
increased, and therefore,
lifetime value increased.
Today, audio is really at the
center of the whole company
and of the product.
So we have the
audio product, which
is the main way how people
consume content today
at Blinkist.
We launched podcasts.
We have one really well-working
podcast called "Simplify"
with more than a couple
of million of downloads
where we talk to book
authors about their life
and about their books.
We also have actions
for Google Assistant.
I think this is how it's called.
Right?
I don't call it Skills.
That would be another company.
[LAUGHTER]
Just the way we
think about audio--
audio is really the center
of all products we build now,
and audio is also
a big, big topic
for innovation at Blinkist.
So in the Blinkist style--
so that's the story of
how we got to audio.
How we started, and I tried
to distill the key messages
from this talk, and what
we are doing at Blinkist
is we are distilling the
key insights from books.
I tried to distill the key
insights from this talk.
And the key message of
this presentation is--
and excuse me for this
very long sentence,
but you might know that
Germans like long words
and long sentences.
I have to read it
because it's so long.
But it is, "User-centric
product innovation can help you
to unlock value by expanding
your value proposition."
Laura, you should have one.
Maybe four.
But this is like--
what I mean by that is I
think it's very important
when you think about
building new products
and try to do innovation that
you focus on your customers.
Listen to your customers.
Try to understand
their problems.
Try to find needs that
are not served yet,
rather than approaching
this from a business side.
Saying oh yeah, it would
be cool if we had that.
And then try to
build that, and then
try to charge more for that.
That won't work.
But if you really try
to understand customers
and what they are facing,
what problems they have
and what you can
solve, then this
is a good opportunity
to introduce this.
And also increase prices,
which then unlocks value
for your company and
for the business.
The first one-- the Blink
number one of this presentation
is, the "impact is hard
to estimate beforehand."
So as you see for
audio, we pushed it off.
Then we said, OK, we'd do it.
We didn't know if it's
going to work out or not.
So what we knew is there
is a need for audio,
but we didn't know
if Blinkist is
the right product and the right
solution to serve this need.
So you could discuss
this for years.
We did.
Or just try it.
And I think it's important
that you do research,
but I believe strongly
in that at some point,
you have to trust
your intuition,
or listen to your
gut saying OK, you
have to collect a lot of data.
Look at that, but then you
have to make a decision based
on that.
So what we do at
Blinkist, we call
this data-driven
intuition, which basically
means we collect data, but the
data won't give you the answer.
You have to still make a
leap of faith at some point,
because you will never
have perfect data to make
a decision.
And sometimes, timing.
Often, timing is
super important.
So one thing when
it comes to audio
at Blinkist, what
is important is
when you look at when
we launched audio,
it's end of November 2014, so we
were working for three months.
So we started in September
more or less, working on audio.
In October 2014, the Serial
podcast was launched,
and Serial podcast,
in hindsight,
is probably the podcast
that opened up audio again
for a whole generation or
for basically everyone.
And that's very
interesting, because we
didn't create this trend.
But we were basically
at the same time,
maybe arriving at
the same insight,
or just there at the right time.
Because suddenly,
audio was the thing,
and everyone was looking
for audio products.
Without Serial, I'm not sure if
Blinkist audio would have been
that successful, to be honest.
But you don't know before and
you just have to try that.
So timing, obviously
is important.
But without trying,
you will never
be able to capitalize on trends.
The second key insight here
is "Start to learn by doing."
"Keep the down side covered."
So I think what we try to
avoid is just building business
plans just creating these Excel
sheets and then say yes or no.
But say OK, there
is ideas we have.
Let's test it.
But let's test it so that we
have the down side covered.
We don't invest
in the whole team.
We build a lean experiment
with what we think
is needed to validate that,
and then we run with that,
and then we see if we want
to double down on it or not.
And I think for us,
this squad that we used,
assembled of these five
people, was really crucial
for the success of the project,
because these people were
passionate about it.
So we didn't need to
motivate them, saying hey,
you're working on this.
Now please can you come
and make it happen?
They made it happen because
they wanted to make it happen,
and they spent all the time
doing research about audio.
They spent all the time
going into the details
to find a really, really
good audio experience.
They spent all the time
on figuring out, fixing
all the bugs in
the audio player,
so we had a really good
product for a first version,
but still in a very lean way.
The third insight is,
"When it comes to pricing,
users often create their
own pricing analogies
for your product."
So as I said before, you can be
very scientific about pricing.
This might work.
I don't know.
We never tried it.
For us what worked is
just looking at the market
and finding comparables,
because this is what,
in our experience, people will
mostly make pricing decisions
based on.
They will look what other
products are charging.
They know, based on that,
they will make a decision
if your product is
cheap or expensive.
Of course, if you're in a
market where basically there
is no comparable product, then
you're in a very good position,
but if you're in
entertainment, education,
there are comparable products.
And the default
comparable product
for everything that has to
do with content, I feel,
is either Spotify or
Netflix, because this
is what people will always
compare you to in the end.
Because they know what
value they get there,
and if you try to be
much more expensive,
then either you need
something very, very exclusive
or a very, very small market
niche where people say,
OK, I need this
for my profession
and I'm paying for
whatever is needed.
Or you try to stick
within the frame what
other companies are charging.
The last insight.
Blink number four is,
"Be ready to fail."
Even the best ideas can fail.
So as I said, we didn't
know if audio was
going to be successful or not.
For us, it was successful.
But of course, you can fail.
And we had another
big experiment.
We believed strongly in
community at Blinkist.
We talked to customers
again, and we
thought we heard
them telling us,
hey, it would be cool if you
could have sharing features
and I could comment and I
could share within Blinkist.
And we thought cool, because the
business is very interested in
that too, so if we had a viral
growth component at Blinkist,
we might grow faster and
we don't have to invest
that much money marketing.
So I think in hindsight, it
was more like the business side
speaking and us just
hearing something we
wanted to hear about community.
We launched it.
We worked six months on this
and it was probably the worst
feature we ever launched.
Probably because
we didn't really
pay attention to our customers,
but more to the business
interest, and it
failed spectacularly.
So that can happen, and I think
just you can learn from that
and try to do it
better next time.
What's very important, as
I said, be ready to fail.
Therefore, start small.
Don't bet the whole
company on one idea,
but just find a way
to do it in a way
that you can always exit
easily without making
it too hard to get out of it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]